el presidente nayib bukele y subirse
Félix Ulloa ya son precandidatos por el
partido nuevas ideas para reelegirse en
esos mismos cargos en las próximas
elecciones en El Salvador programadas
para febrero de 2024 recordemos que en
septiembre de 2022 bukele anunció su
decisión de correr como candidato a la
presidencia de la república Y ahora que
se anunció oficialmente su
precandidatura miles de sus seguidores
expresaron su respaldo al mandatario no
obstante también los cuestionamientos No
tardaron en llegar es el caso del
director ejecutivo de la ong acción
ciudadana Eduardo Escobar que considera
que este proceso contiene vicios de ley
que le restan legitimidad a la
precandidatura esto en razón de que la
Constitución de la República prohíbe en
varios artículos la reelección
presidencial sin embargo una sentencia
de la Corte Suprema de Justicia de 2021
yo paso a esta habilitación Este primer
escalón de bukele en ruta la Cia
presidencial se da en momentos en que
continúa manteniendo una imagen
favorable tras cuatro años en el poder
según una reciente encuesta de la
universidad centroamericana José Simeón
Cañas 89 de cada 100 salvadoreños opinan
que el gobierno aún representa un cambio
positivo para el país con este caudal de
popularidad bukele figura como el
posible ganador de las elecciones
internas de su partido y parte como gran
favorito para ganar Las presidenciales
del país